describe the amazing Jonathan in one
word
crazy I'm eating a razorblade for your
entertainment pleasure mostly it was
this force of nature coming at you that
was then he's a big steamroller that
kept attacking yeah he takes the worst
parts of other magic acts and makes them
actually a good part of him sometimes
magic sounds like tank thank you like
all the way down magic it's everything
magic is my life I can do whatever I
want and they laughs don't take your
eyes off the spoon when I started
working with Jonathan I would hear about
Joel my dad got us tickets to go through
the amazing Jonathan it was like a
freight train and me sitting there as a
12 year old thinking that's what I want
to do when I grow up Joel had an
obsession with Jonathan used to camp out
in front of my hotel room you call me up
and said when I do this commercial it
paces $60,000 for one-day taping I'm
like maybe this isn't a creepy little
kid and at the end of it Jonathan said
to me you want to move out in the States
and be my road manager you know yes I do
you stuck with me I'll be saving my life
through all that
my heart is failing I can't do shows
anymore because my legs lock up it's
kind of a Andy Kaufman thing you don't
really believe it
I still hope in my heart that he's just
kidding I need to prove that I can still
go out there and do it I just sided to
go back out and do one last tour if he
drops dead on stage that's probably the
way he'd want to go on hey Jonathan
seeing you take the stage like a freight
train
I wanted to be part of that world not
knowing where that train was headed was
part of the adventure behind all the
crazy drug taking manic bravado I see
the kind generous caring person I know
you to be
you